[Musique]
nauru naru ça veut pas dire bonjour
naouss c'est une petite île perdue au
milieu du pacifique où vivent
paisiblement une dizaine de milliers
d'habitants ménard ou un secret elle
cache un trésor
ce trésor c'est du phosphate est un art
ou du phosphate y en a beaucoup
alors quand dans les années 70 le
gouvernement décide de lancer
l'exploitation de ce phosphate tous les
habitants vont avoir le droit à leur
part du gâteau
en fait du jour au lendemain
cette petite île va devenir l'un des
pays les plus riches au monde par
habitant alors intrigué la revue
américaine national geographic décide
d'envoyer au milieu des années 70 un
reporter sur place et il ramène cette
photo qui résume assez bien la situation
de la roue à l'époque en arrière plan le
sol est complètement ravagée par les
opérations d'extraction du phosphate et
au premier plan une magnifique rolls
royce haut pour information on fait le
tour de l'île de nauru en une demi heure
les loyers les vacances les études des
enfants à l'étranger
à l'époque un art où tout ça c'est
gratuit ces pays par le gouvernement
avec l'argent du phosphate
mais malheureusement quelques décennies
plus tard du phosphate b y en a plus et
de l'argent mais on a pris non plus les
belles voitures de luxe importés a pris
dehors du monde entier sont maintenant
des tas de rouille dans les jardins une
grande majorité de la population est au
chômage
narbonne a plus de choix pour trouver
son salut
elle doit se tourner ou peut se
retourner vers la mer et justement
laissez moi vous présenter slade slade
il travaille au ministère des pêches de
now et son métier tous les matins c'est
d'aller à la rencontre des pêcheurs et
leur poser tout un tas de questions
ou est ce que tu as été pêché
combien de poissons tard à mener quelles
espèces les réponses à ces questions là
viendront plus tard alimenter une base
de données qui pourraient être
interrogés par la communauté
scientifique ou bien des économistes
pour répondre à des questions comme est
ce que la sécurité alimentaire de tel
village est assurée ou bien est-ce que
le stock de telles espèces de poissons
est en danger et moi mon métier là
dedans eh ben c'est pas compliqué c'est
de design et et de maintenir ses bases
de données
en fait moi je suis informaticien je
suis pas du tout pêcheur et des gens
comme slade il en existe sur la plupart
des îles du pacifique et pour collecter
cette donnée ils ont à leur disposition
un outil absolument révolutionnaire un
crayon et du papier
en fait rien n'a changé depuis les
années 70 et cette donnée là tant
qu'elle est sur du papier en fait elle
n'a aucune valeur
c'est même l'inversé pour l'instant elle
a coûté du temps et elle a coûté de
l'argent
la première chose qui va pas leur faire
c'est la ressaisir dans un ordinateur
et quand on commence à saisir plusieurs
fois la même chose c'est là qu'on fait
des erreurs mais en plus de ça certains
observateurs travail sur ce que l'on
appelle des îles extérieures
c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent être à
plusieurs centaines voire plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres de l'endroit où
la donne et va être saisie ça veut dire
que on va mettre des mois à mettre les
mains sur ces formulaires si il arrive
et ça m'a coûté une fortune en transport
alors vous l'aurez peut-être compris il
ya trois problématiques principales à
tout ça il ya le délai parce que
pacifique c'est grand il ya le coup
parce que le fred c'est cher et puis à
la qualité de la donnée à cause de la
double saisie alors en 2015 et essayer
de me lancer dans un projet développé
une application mobile qui permettrait
de résoudre tous ces problèmes d'un coup
notre observateur au lieu de saisir sur
un formulaire papier et ben ils
saisiraient directement sur une tablette
et puis quand il aura fini son interview
eh ben ils nous enverra les informations
directement dans le cloud plus de délais
plus de coups et plus de double saisie
mais en plus de ça
je décide de rajouter ma petite touche
personnelle une carte interactive qui
permettra aux pêcheurs d' appuyer
directement sur la tablette pour nous
dira j'ai été touché à tel endroit ou
bien j'ai été pêché à tel endroit
et puis je passe beaucoup de temps à
essayer d'optimiser l'application pour
fonctionner sur des connexions internet
très faible ce que je me dis bon des
petites îles dans le pacifique
internet ça va ramer au bout de deux
mois j'ai mon prototype
je suis assez content et je me dis bon
il est temps de tester en fait il lui
manque juste une chose à cette
application c'est un nom et décide de
l'appeler is comme l'accueil du poisson
en anglais deux jours plus tard je suis
à now avec slade dont je vous ai parlé
juste avant il ya trois pêcheurs qui
arrivent en même temps alors forcément
il ya l'adrénaline qui monte en même
temps je suis chaud patate parce que je
me dis je vais voir ce que tales a dans
le ventre et évidemment ça va pas se
passer comme prévu
slade n'y arrive pas avec l'application
il est extrêmement lent pour saisir la
donnée est en face de nous on a des
pêcheurs ça fait cinq six heures qui
sont en mer
là tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est vendre
leur poisson et rentrer chez eux pour
aller se reposer
alors forcément ils s'impatientent puis
au bout d'un moment il s'agace à ce
moment-là slate sans que ça commence à
être tendu il re dégaine son vieux
formulaire papier que les pêcheurs
connaissent bien et la situation se
calme mais moi à ce moment-là j'ai
qu'une envie c'est de prendre une pelle
de creuser un trou et de me cacher
dedans parce que le soir d'avant la
première fois que j'ai rencontré slide
je lui ai vendu du rêve
je lui ai dit ce pas compliqué tales ça
va changer ta vie au lieu de au lieu
d'aller saisir une seconde fois toutes
les données après les avoir interrogés
les pêcheurs tu pourrais rentrer chez
toi directement bon ce ne sera pas pour
aujourd'hui
et en plus de ça il est passé pour un
clown devant les pêcheurs et les
pêcheurs c'est des gens qui sont assez
compliqué c'est très difficile d'avoir
leur confiance alors on se pose quand
même pour débriefer et je suis assez
surpris il est plutôt positif sur
l'outil lui il y voit son intérêt
personnel forcément il dit si ça marche
ça va me rendre la vie plus facile
alors il met nu mer tous les trucs qui
vont pas dans tales et y en a beaucoup
tous les boutons qui vont nulle part
tous les endroits où il ya trop
d'informations moi je prends des notes
et je dis bah écoute c'est pas compliqué
si tu veux demain même heure même
endroit on réessaie et puis moi j'aurais
intégrer toutes tes observations une vie
ok là demain je commence à partir vers
ma mobylette et là il fait un temps
juste un truc ta carte interactive là ça
marchera jamais les pêcheurs quand on
les interroge ils font autre chose
ils nettoient leurs bateaux ils
nettoient leurs poissons ils sont hyper
pressé ya jamais aucun pêcheur au monde
qui à ce moment-là prendra le temps
d'aller appuyé sur ta tablette pour te
dire ah j'étais à tel endroit ou bien
j'étais alors on laisse tomber je dis ok
on fait quoi
tu prends tu met à la poubelle si tu
savais le temps que ça m'a appris à
faire cette carte
tant pis le lendemain matin je retrouve
slade avec un nouveau tales et puis j'ai
dit on change les règles du jeu ce coup
là moi je prends le formulaire papier
toi tu prends l'application dit moi je
note tout ce que le pêcheur il est comme
ça y'a pas de problème on perdra pas
d'information toi tu essayes de
dépatouiller et puis tu me dises qui va
pas on débriefe à nouveau la journée
j'aurais améliore tales on se retrouve
le lendemain et on continue notre manège
pendant trois ou quatre jours
et au bout de trois ou quatre jours
slide arrive à saisir dans tales un
formulaire aussi rapidement que moi sur
le papier
quand je dis bah écoute essaye de
l'envoyer dans le cloud ça se trouve ça
par contre ça va marcher du premier coup
et bizarrement ça marche on a réussi on
a bien galéré
on a réussi alors
franchement mobylette et puis je pense
au ministère des pêches de nauru et la
première chose qui me disent quand
j'arrive 10 by your side 300 g chez lui
il a fini sa journée de boulot il n'a
pas besoin de revenir pour saisir à
nouveau ces données et je vais vous
montrer sur l'ordinateur que tout ce
qu'on a subi ce matin c'est déjà
disponibles c'est déjà disponible pour
vous mais en plus cela on est relié au
cloud directement donc c'est déjà
disponible pour les scientifiques
c'est déjà disponible pour les
économistes plus de délais plus de coups
plus de double saisie
le contrat est rempli alors il est
malheureusement temps de quitter slade
et quitter now et débris c'est un peu
cette mission et là je me dis la
première chose c'est j'ai eu énormément
de chance de tomber sur lui parce qu'il
a été très ouvert très honnête il y a
évidemment vu son intérêt personnel
et puis en plus le premier jour vous
avec les pêcheurs ça s'est pas bien
passé du tout bon il est intervenu et là
je me suis dit je suis quand même tombé
sur un chic type
moi par contre je me rends compte que
j'ai débarqué à nauru je savais pas du
tout où je mettais les pieds
j'avais une application mobile relié au
cloud installés sur des tablettes avec
leur internet que je pense est
catastrophique
je me disais une petite île de 10000
habitants est ce qu'ils vont même
réussir à savoir s'en servir
donc quand je suis arrivé ils avaient
tous des smartphones now he ou bloquent
l'accès à facebook mais tous les jeunes
utilisent des vpn pour se géolocaliser
dans d'autres pays pour quand même
accéder à facebook
bon j'ai pris une énorme claque et je me
suis dit en fait je suis resté trop
longtemps dans mon bureau parce que
tales j'ai pas vraiment mis deux mois à
le faire en fait j'ai mis un mois le
deuxième mois j optimisée pour les
connexions internet faible et j'ai fait
une carte interactive est forcément si
j'avais été sur le terrain ou et d'un
mois je me serais rendu compte que ces
deux choses a été complètement inutiles
alors en prenant un peu de recul je me
suis dit qu'avec un un projet innovant
comme tales
il faut garder à l'esprit que si tu dois
te planter fait le vite parce que à
partir du moment où on innove il faut
accepter qu'on peut se planter sinon on
n'innove pas mais si on peut se planter
le plus vite possible ça permet de
pivoter vers quelque chose qui va
fonctionner voire même de complètement
annulé
à ce moment là on peut dire à son chef
dont j'ai essayé ça a pris un mois c'est
pas non plus une catastrophe
problème c'est quand on est avec eux
pendant six mois on sort pas de son
bureau et qu'on se rend compte que en
fait ce qu'on a fait ça servait à rien
là le budget il commence à être un peu
élevé pour une erreur alors j'étais
super content non slogan je me suis je
vais breveté je vais faire des t-shirts
je vais devenir consultant ça va être
génial
puis je me suis rendu compte rapidement
qu'en fait ça fait une dizaine d'années
que la silicon valley il développe les
logiciels comme ça là bas ils ont même
une conférence qui s'appelle la falcon
ou les spectateurs payent pour venir
voir des conférenciers leur expliquer
tous les projets où ils sont plantés et
toutes les erreurs qu'ils ont fait comme
ça ils apprennent des erreurs des autres
et non pas à les faire eux mêmes en fait
c'est un peu ce que vous faites là c'est
un peu ma falcone en ce moment donc si
un informaticien qui me regarde en ce
moment et qu'ils ya dans mon application
de pêche je vais mettre une carte non tu
vas pas le faire parce que c'est nul
et là je ne te faire économiser un mois
mon pote de rien
bon il est 18 mois suivant j'ai des
plots et lg dans plein d'autres pays du
pacifique et des claques j'en ai pris
plein je me souviens de cette fois où je
débarque dans un pays est en fait il
fallait fallait se dépêcher parce que
les pêcheurs allaient arriver donc je
donne les tablettes aux observateurs
j'en dis bon les gars par contre on se
dépêche a en outre même pas les
tablettes joubouri frais dans le bus
allez hop hop hop on speed cinq minutes
après je me retourne je tombe sur ce
type là je m'approche un peu juste mais
qu'est ce que tu fais il me tend sa
tablette en cinq minutes
lequel avait mis sa carte 3g perso dans
la tablette il avait téléchargé une
application de voip et il appelait ses
potes de son île un par un pour leur
dire qu'ils avaient un mec qui venait de
lui filer une tablette gratos effet les
gages pour c'est techniquement il était
là dans les mecs qui sont là ils savent
très bien ce qu'ils font les gars une
autre fois j'étais sur un petit atoll
perdu au milieu du pacifique
sur les marches de ma chambre d'hôte le
soir puis un petit jeune 12 13 ans qui
m'approchent c'est un peu timidement et
qui me fait ses toiles blanc qui vient
d'arriver qui t'y connais en
informatique
gibeau a été comme ça il y en a pas de
là on s'est vus on est là et il me pose
la question que tous les informaticiens
des tests est ce que tu peux m'aider
avec mon ordinateur
on n'aime pas vous aider avec vos
ordinateurs
on n'aime pas ça arrêtez de me le
demander mais bon là je suis sur place
il a l'air sympa je dis ok allez vas-y
montre un mois il revient cinq minutes
après avec un ordinateur portable plutôt
pas mal s'assure à côté de moi il
l'ouvrît des marges regarde un peu il
sous linux le gamin a pas mal et puis
commence à taper des lignes de commande
là il prend leur dit mme lemay sur la
joue une fille regarde ça marche pas je
regarde sur son écran il essayer de
résoudre un exercice de c++ et c++
c'est un des langages de programmation
informatique les plus compliqués qu'ils
existent alors je dis attend déjà
explications qu'est que tu fais quoi là
il m'explique il s'est inscrit à des
cours de programmation en ligne et en
plus il a choisi le langage de
programmation le plus compliqué comme ça
à prendre les autres langages ce sera
plus facile
la démarche intellectuelle du gamin bon
et puis moi du c++ sous linux
j'en ai pas fait depuis la fac je
regarde l'écran je comprends rien c'est
pas compliqué donc dans ces cas-là
technique normale
on gagne du temps donc j'ai dit bon
écoute si je te donne la réponse c'est
pas comme ça que tu vas apprendre
résultat bon je lui dis à mon avis ton
problème
il est par là alors tu regardes tu
cherches un peu par toi même
1 et puis bon moi je suis dans cette
chambre d'hôte toute la semaine occitane
si t'arrives pas à trouver tu reviens et
puis j'espère être expliquer un peu plus
bon je n'ai plus jamais revu en soit
j'ai eu de la chance mais bon soit il a
surtout compris qu'en fait je comprenais
rien bright eyes dans tout ça et ben
spies en 2017 a remplacé 90% des
formulaires papier qu on manipulait
avant la main et avant toute chose en
fait c'est un sentiment de fierté que je
ressens parce que cette application là
c'est moi qui en ai eu l'idée c'est moi
qui les développer bon vous l'avez
compris c'est moi qui me suis planté
mais en écoutant les gens qui savent
ben j'ai réussi a finalement faire une
application qui fonctionne et de savoir
qu'aujourd'hui quelque part dans le
pacifique et des observateurs comme
slade qui ont utilisé cette application
là pour nous envoyer de la donner en
live eh ben c'est un moment extrêmement
fier mais en fait
l'ingrédient principal de la réussite de
ce projet bah c'est eux
ce sont ces femmes et ces hommes qui
collecte de la donner sur le terrain
tous les jours et qui par leur retour
ont permis de mettre au coeur de taste
ou leur savoir-faire et toutes leurs
connaissances et en fait maintenant
s'ils utilisent autant cette application
c'est parce qu'elle ressemble un petit
peu malheureusement tales ça fait que
collecter de la donner il faudra des
mois peut-être même des années avant que
les économistes ou les scientifiques
fassent parler cette donnée et la
transforme en informations
et c'est cette information-là qui
servira au gouvernement ou bien aux
autorités régionales de prendre les
bonnes décisions pour pérenniser la vie
dans leur famille et dans leur
communauté
et si ça arrive
alors je saurai que non seulement j'ai
fait une application qui fonctionne mais
surtout j'aurais fait une application
utile pour eux et c'est je pense la
meilleure façon pour moi de les
remercier pour tout ce qu'ils m'ont
appris et tout ce qu'ils m'ont apporté
merci
[Applaudissements]